welcome back three men accused of
helping plot the kidnapping of
Michigan's Governor have been convicted
on state charges of providing support
for a terrorist act Joe Morrison his
father-in-law Pete miowsko and Paul
Bellar were members of a militia group
known as The Wolverine Watchman the
group's leader put together a plot to
kidnap Michigan Governor Gretchen
Whitmer in hopes they could start a
Civil War the FBI stopped the plot
before any violence happened using
undercover agents and informants to get
information defense attorneys argued
none of the men knew about the
kidnapping plot and nothing they did was
a crime the jury deliberated for only a
few hours before returning a verdict
Morrison tested positive for covid-19
earlier this week and his father-in-law
had symptoms so they watched the verdict
via webcam
on December 15th and the men looking at
decades in prison kind of give us like a
30 000 foot view of this what do you
think will actually get for jail time
well I think they're going to get as
much as the prosecution can argue that
they should get because they're trying
to set an example here these are very
serious charges and the Gang membership
count plus the account for providing
support of terrorist act those carry a
maximum of 20-year sentences and under
the Michigan sentencing guidelines if
you have a felony and the court has
discretion those guidelines are going to
apply and the judge is going to look at
whether or not they had former charges
whether or not they have committed other
felonies and it does really depend on
each individual you could see
differences in each of the defendants
depending on whether or not they have
records so it remains to be seen but I
think the prosecution is going to push
for the maximum well Dina drill down a
little deeper for us do you think the
judge is going to say hey Max is 20 I
give you all 20 in like the same amount
of jail time or will it vary and if it
does how does it vary based on their
participation in this case
well as we know there's actually going
to be a hearing on the sentencing and
part of what each of the defendants can
do is show remorse accept responsibility
and show remorse and that will make a
difference and could make it that they
have different sentences depending on
how they act during that sentencing
hearing and as Terry said did they have
any priors were their participation
radically different in any way I think
the big thing the Hing though is because
this involved the kidnapping of a
governor a really big factor is
deterrence in any sentencing and I think
that might make it that they all apply
the same since they were all convicted
of this really serious charge in terms
of deterring others from doing the same
thing makes sense thank you for that and
another story out of the Midwest where
surveillance cameras caught in video of
a drunk driving crash in Eau Claire
Wisconsin take a look
thank you
Please Release the video this week
showing a car Veer off the road and
crash into a stopped car and traffic
light the car then rolled over and onto
another car in a nearby parking lot
officials say the crash happened at
about 9 30 in the morning on Saturday
October 22nd please identify the driver
as 22 year old Nicholas Ives who was
arrested with a first offense OWI and
second-degree recklessly endangering
safety officials say his portable breath
test result was .242 in Wisconsin the
legal limit is .08 in a Facebook pose
detailing the crash please confirm there
were injuries but no one was killed in
the crash